five lives ended in this basement
their bodies lie face up hands bound
mouths contorted
the men all allegedly killed by russian
soldiers
ukrainian officials carry them out
the horror deliberately on display
then zipped up as evidence of more
suspected war crimes in this town just
outside kiev
we watched as the binds that were
holding their hands behind their back
were cut these bodies are now being
taken away for burial an official
involved in the process said that over
the past few weeks here in butcher he's
found around 300 bodies he said about
thirty percent of them were women and
children and he believes that more are
going to be found
this latest grim discovery was at a
children's holiday camp
the names of boys and girls who once
stayed here written on the walls
then russian forces turned it into a
base before they were turfed out
a man tasked with burying bodies in
butcher said he'd never seen such
horrors
ukraine's president agreed
he came to see and hear for himself what
happened in this town his first public
appearance outside kiev since the war
began
[Music]
is
[Music]
there are still uncollected bodies in
the open three days since russian forces
withdrew
russia's denied responsibility for any
civilian deaths in butcher
but arena showed us three makeshift
graves dug round the back of her
apartment block
she said the men buried here were all
randomly killed by russian troops
irina even witnessed one her neighbor
being shot in the back of the head
what
ukrainian officials also showed us a
shallow grave in woods in a nearby
village
in it were four bodies partially buried
one of the victims was named as
olhasenko the local mayor pictured here
with her husband and son
officials said she'd refused to
cooperate with russian forces so all
three were shot dead along with a
volunteer soldier
ukraine believes what's so far been
uncovered is just the tip of the iceberg
with much more death lurking below
debra haynes sky news butcher